tous
[Musique]
où
voilà donc bienvenu bienvenue pour ce
match de la troisième place de ce grand
prix pour savoir qui va terminer
troisième de ce grand prix des chèques
2007 alors un petit récapitulatif de ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
et bien c'est d'abord mathieu cornette
qui a battu laurent frayssinet au
départage donc rejoint la finale de ce
grand prix 2007 en créant la surprise du
jour la plus importante
il est l'un des favoris du tournoi après
avoir éliminé après que les le deuxième
favori charmante de schiste se soit fait
éliminer par mathieu cornette hier et
dans la deuxième demi finale
et bien c'est romain edouard qui a
disposé de alberto david là aussi dans
les départage très très très chaud donc
le jeune maître international qui jouera
la finale tout à l'heure alors voilà
donc là ce match pour la troisième place
va donc on va voir se voir affronter
voir s'affronter alberto d'avis et
laurent frayssinet alors je vous
rappelle le principe de grand prix pour
ceux qui viendraient maintenant donc
écrans géants ici où on peut suivre donc
les parties si on à la fin du match
précédent donc deux parties de 20
minutes par joueur en cas d'égalité il y
aura des blitz de départage de blitz de
cinq minutes par joueur
et en cas de nouvelle égalité alors il
ya un beat ce mort subite cinq minutes
aux blancs et 4 noir et dans ce cas là
les blancs sont obligés de gagner en cas
de match nul ce sont les noirs qui sont
déclarés vainqueurs
voilà donc que vous avez des casques
site vous permet d'écouter les
commentaires qui seront données par
renault laguna président de l'échiquier
bordelais ainsi que le modem donc pour
comprendre les coûts qui se déroule sur
l'échiquier
voilà donc pour ce match de la troisième
place important pour savoir qui va
rentrer sur le sur le podium
tout d'abord nous allons accueillir
un grand maître luxembourgeois double
vainqueur du championnat de paris qui
s'est fait éliminé de justesse tout à
l'heure par le jeune roumain edward
c'est un très grand champion je demande
d'applaudir le grand maître
international alberto david alberto
david bonsoir alberto donc pas je pense
troisième place donc bon évidemment
c'est un peu dommage de rater la finale
mais c'est quand même match important
face à laurent frayssinet un match qui
peut compter quand même pour la suite
il ya un ascendant psychologique à
prendre sur entre les joueurs mais aussi
va chercher à prendre un ascendant
psychologique non c'est toujours un
plaisir de jouer contre vous jouez
effectivement donc on va voir aussi un
très beau match pour cette troisième
place donc je vous demande d'applaudir
aussi le prochain joueur il est grand
maître international numéro 4 français
50e joueur mondial champion de france
glisse vice-champion d'europe de blitz
d'opposition tour du monde chez les
jeunes est deux fois vainqueur de
l'équipe de russie avec l'équipe de
france
le grand maître international laurent
frayssinet leur offre estimée à laurent
donc le dernier match de ce grand prix
donc c'est pas la finale mais bon la
troisième place à jouer quand même voilà
donc ce spectacle donc au risque d'avoir
une autre partie pour arbitrer ce match
et je veux remercier encore d'avoir
accepté de venir avec les ce match il a
remplacé un arbitre international qui
devait venir qui n'a pas pu et il est
régionale il est arbitre souvent tous
les tournois importants de la région que
ce soit en gironde wire je vous demande
d'applaudir l' arbitre international
patrick basse patrick besse voilà merci
stéphane comme il voulait expliquer deux
parties de 20 minutes par joueur
donc nous allons tirer bien entendu au
sort la couleur chacun d'entre eux
qui décide
[Musique]
laurent frayssinet a gagné le toss et a
choisi de débuter le match avec les
pièces noirs ici lamine sy contentant dé
lever la main on va juste se caler nous
nous calons voilà donc ces partis
lapertot david a choisi de prendre les
blancs ou russie mémoire j'ai pas suivi
voilà david les blancs freyssinet les
noirs une italienne ou une italienne
défense des deux cavaliers donc tout à
l'un d'eux s'est caractérisée réel au
début et donc le conte moderne des trois
c4 le moderne des trois fosses et sic
alors que dans les autres variantes de
l'après midi on avait vu le coût fawcett
le coup ici vous voilà important de mon
prix de 15 euros nous allons abandonner
des variantes voilà dans cet aprem
aisément pris cette soirée c'est le fou
qui va ans essec
voilà on voit la flèche bleue qui
montrera toujours le dernier coup joué
par les joueurs des six libérant le fou
lukas blanche alors voilà t on veut
éviter le noyage fou le fond j'ai quatre
mais il a joué cavalier bd2 parce que se
clôt âge mais on ne peut pas vraiment
exploité la casse des quatre états ont
contrôlé par le pian ses trois succès
des deux en k2 en cas de fonte g4 cube
blanc n'ont pas peur ils vont jouer h3
suivi du g4 et ensuite cavalier fait un
câble et j30 voilà assis qu'on peut même
le jouer avant de roquet cavalier fait
l'objet croire c'était les vieilles
variantes de tennis qui a amélioré son
cavalier avant de faire le petit rock
alors bien sûr conseille à tous les
débutants de roquettes au mais
quelquefois au rock trop tôt en bout la
rocqué tôt
les règles sont là pour être
transgressée graissé et c'est justement
tout l'air des grands champions alors
c'est le diable se matures nous puisque
c'est la troisième place 1 ça aurait pu
être la finale oui bien sûr ça pour être
leader c'est un peu comme si on avait
brésil allemagne pour la troisième place
en fait entre ville a précisé et alberto
david et la force et des joueurs et on
aura une superbe finale quand même entre
deux superbes jeunes joueurs qu'on a eu
raison d'inviter un oui mais oui parce
que les spectacles dans leur partie en
pièces chic et vibre fait le panache
quel panache et oui toujours prêts à
attaquer et ne recule pas donc là
peut-être une partie de manoeuvre avec
ces deux joueurs voilà cavaliers général
et à 30 ans quand la tension la menace
évidemment ici de laurent frayssinet
c'est tout simplement oui de gagner le
pied en f2 et +6 accord si encore en vie
dans ce secteur les convives deux
attaques
la dame est pour on appelle ça une
fourchette fourchette donc là dès le col
des forces naturelles le rock qui
déforme
voilà donc rocky la tour évidemment de
défendre le pion donc et c'est bizarre
ce court puisque évidemment quand les
dés blancs dont joue h3 on voit pas trop
où aller le cavalier venait se sacrifier
en f2 sa déchéance ça donne chez un
exemple de chance mais du coup c'est ce
coût a l'air complètement inutiles petit
rocla devant être signé très bizarre que
jouent les noirs sur h3 oui pourquoi
cavaliers g4 belle et noires partiront
peut-être il voudrait devenir un assist
pour jouer wall street et f5
il veut jouer f5 il a déjà joué à 25
dans les deux parties qu'il a jouées
contre mathieu cornette ses conseils me
rende borderline que nous fait rentrer
signer là donc il essaie d'améliorer
cesser ces partis jouer qu'entre
cornette avec le même le même début donc
il essaie une autre idée cavaillé g4
cette fois mais avec le temps cachent
trois attaques
michael j 4 alors là si on veut jouer f5
il va falloir le mettre 1 h 6 sur le
maire dû 6e renault on peut jouer le
simple coût des cavaliers mais trois qui
attaquent le faut et qui menace de
détruire de détruire la structure noire
menace de prendre peur sur le roc et
emma l'associent faux prince si des
menaces fou prend cavalli qui casserait
la structure de route ford et reprendre
du pillon avoir l'avion complètement
azimuté sur le bord de l'échiquier
alors c'est peut-être ça va être un beau
match les joueurs vont vouloir sortir de
ce grand prix de bordeaux avec un bon
souvenir
ils ont raté la finale de très très près
alors il existe des dépositions comme ça
aux anges ou h5
quelque 9,6 peut-être un jour h5
quelquefois et sacrifient rallier mais
c'est ouais mais serra ou non le furent
général quand la tour est en cours la
voilà car at war est encore là et comme
cela quand les blancs prennent on
reprend du pied voilà et la tour et
ensuite la dame mais la dame mois ci et
on va mater mais là cette position il
sent la tour oui voilà c'est clair que
ça n'avait pas lieu d'être
alors voilà dans la création qu'il a
perdu du temps il a perdu un oeil temps
mais il a forcé son adversaire à faire
le petit rock et vous ça et à ne pas
jouer le plan qu'il voulait faire avec
cavalli et feurs g3 et cetera mais il a
eu le temps de jouer tourer pour jouer
ce fameux coup le cavalière n'est funk
il joue alors là c'est l'exploitation
des femmes
troublant qui sont sur la case des 5 et
sur la case f5 et le cavalier peut viser
alors comme on appelle sa renault le
poil 1,6 et le pion à 6 ha on appelle ça
les oreilles d'âne
donc pourquoi j'appelle ça les oreilles
d'âne parce que de chaque côté de
l'échiquier il ya un petit un petit pion
qui ressemble à une oreille et l'autre
oreille à de chaque côté de la tête au
général d'ida ne pas ce qu'on fait c'est
du coup j'ai néral qui sont qui sont
souvent joués par les débutants
parce que les débiteurs ont tellement
pris de coups cavaliers b5 oui gagner le
pion c'est cette opération chèques etc
quand il y avait le rouennais 8 que
systématiquement et sans réfléchir il
joue à 6h s'ils sont les voilà mais
plein de champion et de grands champions
ont joué les oreilles d'âne avec une
raison là une raison ici la raison du kw
à 6 c'est de protéger les garder vivant
le full attack le fond noir le fossé 5
pour pouvoir le remettre en 7,6 douala
s'il est attaqué bien sûr s'il est
attaqué par des gardes
bien sûr on peut ce recul est acéré
l'idée h6 c'est d'éviter une double idée
en général sur ce coup à six ici c'est
effectivement pourquoi je vous fawcett
est aussi souvent joué on prépare aussi
les cinq bien sûr l'ex-stagiaire
cervelle dame protège lui 5 voilà faut
aussi ce alors fou et 6 voilà c'est un
coût qui recommande départ par la
théorie c'est presque
une position espagnole en fait parce que
c'était une italienne au départ mais le
fou est passé en vendée alors le pion à
six a été joué c'est l'heure des quatre
ans donc d4 à l'intention les noirs
n'ont pas trop le choix parce que la
menace s'est dé saint louis qui gagne
qui gagnait deux pièces non bio il va
falloir que les noirs de toute façon
prennent en mai trois graines ici en b3
je pensais que les noirs en prenant mes
toiles à ses obligés voilà c'est fait
c'est fait on reprend du pillon en
reprend du pillon oui pour laisser la
colonne ouverte
il revient à 7 alors pourquoi ne pas
avoir pris dans ta il voulait pas il
voulait pas donner le centre alors là
c'est un art ou thématiques thématiques
il ne pouvait pas prendre jouer cavalier
3 parce que le câble le pied en 4 et
tête en l'air k23 il y avait pris du cap
du poil 4 en fait tout simplement alors
que la tour évidemment on aurait été
aurait été interceptée par le cavalier
donc il a mis le cavalier en g3 qui
étaient ici au lieu de le mettre là il
l'a mis en général et coin dit de venir
ici sur lacazette cinq ans certains
cadres 5 sur 7 j'en avais parlé hier est
en liaison avec avec le coach 6 quand
les le coin qui s'était jouée la 5000ème
très bonne pub pour un cavalier parce
que ce cavalier difficile marche à saint
palais 6 à cause de cavaliers prend h 6
et celle ci c'est cavaliers prend pions
et ce cavalier donc et puissamment
installé sur la case f5 et valier
kasparov voilà le fameux cavaliers
kasparov là qui rôdent autour du roi
noir et sports qui a déclaré qu' un
cavalier comme ça enlève 5 ou 1 6 4 pour
les noirs oui contre l'europe comme ça
valait un pion balle est un pion et aide
à gagner une partie parce que le cavaly
est une pièce aussi qui peut se
sacrifier pour détruire en rock oui on
pourrait sacrifier angers7 sacrifiant h6
avec l'idée après derrière que le fou
aussi et on gagne la défense la défense
du roi noir
il ya des thèmes tactique alors à noter
quand même renous que tout de suite ce
coût serait pas un bon bout après suite
au couteau 8 pour moi parce que après
pions 30 et 4 puis on prend des cas très
bien le pion au cap yahia statut protégé
ray cavale et prend les atours procès
dans le cerveau liées voilà alors que le
cavalier g3 tout de suite
c'est pour ça qu'ils jouent des cinq
dessins cas là voilà une belle idée la
belle idée c'est de travailler aux sept
voire de gagner de l'espace
il protège à cazères celle qu'il veut
pas que le cavalier vienne arrive cinq
dons qui viennent défendre avec le
cavalier laurent précisé voilà chaque
fois quand réussi à implanter un pion
solide sur une case du camp de
l'adversaire ce qui est le cas de la
casse des cinq la double les cavaliers
david oui oui il va jouer
pourquoi parce qu'il veut venir nous
absolument venir en échange je remplace
par l'autre voilà à noter que moi je
suis très étonné que l'on en fait signer
permettre de rentrer dans ce genre de
variantes parce que laurent frayssinet a
perdu face à mathieu cornette c'est
quasiment une barre anti mine de rien de
similaire avec une attaque avec mon
intérieur et à castagnolles cavaliers
dynamique un exploitation de la case
blanche f5 et puis voilà c'est quand
même c'est quand même incroyable qui le
qui le rend pendant ces 45 il a pas
l'air de d'apprécier et qui ce qu'ils
sont et qui semble très difficile à
jouer difficile à jouer parce que les
pièces blanches arrive terre le roc noir
est ce que ça serait pas assez rabotés
dans la préparation de laurent fait
signer ça c'est énorme je sais pas je
pense que lille joue assez souvent 1,5
il y croire au coup cinq contre quatre
qui est un coup solide et puis à ces
parties espagnoles italiennes là pour me
la joue et rejoue cette façon a vécu
avec une préparation il se penchait déjà
sur ce type de position faudra pas
oublier souffou qui va sûrement jouer un
rôle voilà alors et qui a quand même une
action et nord voilà il ya quand même
quelque chose qui s'est passé ils ch et
oui le noir à préserver sans full attack
alors que le blanc lui l'a perdu leblanc
affaires du sang full attack la foule
cases blanches des blancs alice parizeau
comme un beauf ou d'attac
oh non il est encore vivant sur le ring
tarisa d'étape sur m6 c'est un fou
d'attac alors ce n'est pas une attaque
ça aurait été mieux de taper sur g7 mais
on ne peut pas il ya des billboard 200
il assure ainsi c'est quand même une
cible ce qu'on appelle une seule cible
effet une pression sacrifices imaginons
des choses comme par exemple fouet trois
dames des deux bons il faut de protéger
sa vie non mais faut et 3 d'amener de et
après il faut prendre de la dame ici et
on va essayer de mater rapidement mais
je pense quand même que le plan quand on
a joué quatre des cinq c'est pour
attaquer sur les dames aussi un c'est
pour jouer c4c bkc 4 b 4 puis c5 et
attaquer la chaîne ann ware attaqué
cette chaîne et si oui dans la section
prend des six ont créé une faiblesse
selon lui que soient ses 7 et les
indécis sont ouverts la colonne ici oui
c'est plus dans l'esprit de la position
que la taxe sur le roi qui n'est pas sûr
d'aboutir avec du flou avec les
possibilités des forces d'ailleurs il
était en train de prendre des
précautions en défensive
voilà 11 7 mais moi j'ai l'impression
que en profiter a des soucis avec ses
variantes existent qu'il n'a pas su il
n'a pas su trouver contre mathieu qu'on
en était revenus dans le match grâce à
ça c'est rien parce que sinon ils
avaient quand même perdu
oui clairement la première oui alors si
on regarde aussi le temps voilà qui a
quelques difficultés quand on connaît
bien son sujet quinze minutes 1 sur un
début on n'est pas en retard aux deux
heures dans le début on est en avance ou
un équilibre là il est en retard au
temps dans les bus ça veut dire que
c'est sale alberto david qu'on est mieux
son histoire voilà il a de la difficulté
sur ses variantes laurent frayssinet il
sait pas il sait pas encore peaufiner
son répertoire façon précise sur cette
variante il ya des soucis quand il
revient à 9,8 pour forcer un jour là la
rupture avec le coup f5
il faudrait jouer c'est bien sûr et donc
il va falloir qu'ils sortent le cavalier
willy parce que lacazette ça avec mon
association bien sûr mais il faudrait
qu'ils essaient de s'orienter vers ce à
jouer j'ai 6 puis f5
non mais peut-être qui s'est simplement
dit laurent fasciné que de 67 tours n'a
pas d'avenir ici puisque si bloqués ici
oui je pense je parle il faut défendre
le plus obscène oui mais s'il veut faire
tout ce plan là il va jouer cavalier g8
puis j'ai signé hier 5 leurs cavaliers
qui gêne le cavalier f6 sur wii puis
j'ai 6 puis f5 pour plusieurs sens et
oui mairie avisera qui l'affaiblirait
cette heure il a fait dresser calme et
camier g8 la défendre et c'est pas de
ses livres cavaliers j'évite la cour est
de 3,7 pour défendre deux fois et pour
s'orienter vers le plan de structures
l'a attaqué la chaîne
c'est quand même alors 14 minutes contre
donc ça ce minus et on a vu tellement
hyper mal se décider au temps dans ce
grand prix c'est décidément un grand
prix tout à fait tout à fait
exceptionnel puisqu'il ya que des matchs
décidés au départage
oui des belles empoignades en partie
rapide ou comme match
le seul match terminé avant ses fruits
signer contre wayne aquitaine parce
qu'il y avait carrément les équilibres
de force entre les deux joueurs et
l'expérience sert le grand maître
qu'entre le l'amateur mais voilà c'est
ça va quand même un grand prix
extrêmement disputée à larache c'est
comme si au foot y avait que des matchs
n'évitant pas aux penaltys voilà
cavaliers f5 donc pour au tennis au
tie-break pour changer peut-être un
cavalier freiner le plan de la reprise
donc il va reprendre sans doute du
cavalier voyez reprise du cavalier ce
qui est logique normale et l'autriche y
réfléchir david la voyez réfléchi il
peut reprendre de l'adav aussi bien sur
mais bon on n'y croit pas on n'y crois
pas parce que parce qu'ils auraient g6
avec thème pour aller prendre lavagne
est donc maintenant attention par
exemple imaginons un coup comme on
imaginera pas parce que voilà l'origine
s'oriente vers le plan que dont j'ai
parlé c'est à dire car oui j'ai vite
puis j'ai six cf salle oui oui oui il
faut faire attention quand même un oui
parce que la f3 ya le vis-à-vis de dames
mj quatre médailles aura simplement g6
menace matt g4 y aura simplement g6 et 6
qui attaquent le cas john holmes jkd g6
et il peut pas y avoir un sacrifice ici
à fond après il ne restera que la dame
pour pour attaquer l homme peut pas
venir en hqe est malheureusement la dame
venait hk h4 à cause d' adam levy d'amd
8 malawi donc on peut pas apparemment on
peut pas faire deux choses à la fois là
il veut éliminer ce fou hein quand même
parce qu'il faut pas oublier ce petit
fou mais oui qui quand même est un vrai
poison assez le full attack parce qu'on
oublie on peut l'oublier et seulement la
fin il peut très bien faire un oui parce
qu'il faudra un jour jouer f3 pour
défendre ma position
un coup de jarnac va falloir défendre la
position un jour avec f3 quand il y aura
f5 de jouer donc il veut prendre du
cavalier peut-être joué j'ai quatre
peut-être joué g4 lui-même pour
interdire à jamais at 5 1 pour interdire
f5 pour interdire cette poussée voilà et
puis ensuite il réalisera 6,6
neutralisent le contre le jeu des noirs
sur les le roi comme c'est le cas il
pourra ensuite faire son plan son plan
naturel de l'ale dame dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure ses quatre baies quatre
essais
ces quêtes oui bien sûr médiation que le
fouet c'est bien si la rue voilà s'il
arrive à stabiliser l'est le roi c'est
possible bien vu effectivement c'est
effectivement un plan possible aussi
mais il faut qu'il arrive à stabiliser
de ce côté là alors maintenant g4 se
heurterait à peut-être 5
voilà donc fait signer vient de l'avion
et vient d'activer sa dame le pion et
clou sur une très belle case dans
laquelle j'ai cinq est très intéressante
pour les pour les noirs parce qu'elle se
situe assez loin du cavalier ou trois
qui est la pièce mineurs que la dame
craindrait le plus dans cette position
donc l'état qu'attendu cavaliers elle
est bien oui alors que tu veux dire
quatre temps on m'a expliqué il faut
quatre coups aux cavaliers pour se poser
sur laquelle j'ai cinq et trois coups
pour l'attaqué on ne peut pas en fait
parce que les cases en plus on pourrait
se poser sont occupés oui venir la voilà
éphémère et sur laquelle les habitants
effectivement que l'album soit pas la
regarder le nombre de coups qui
voyez-vous revenir ici cela il faut 1 2
et 3 et 3 po et pour se poser au
quatrième atteint sur la cale derrière
sur laquelle geste c'est pour ça qu'on
dit que en fait même si la dame semble à
2,15 du cavaly en fait elle est à 80 à 4
temps rien puisque c'est ce qu'entend de
temps les déplacements de gueuler
cavaliers sur l'échiquier quatre cases 4
temps effectivement voilà donc c'est un
truc ce que vous devez savoir pour les
jouer contre les cavaliers
mettez-vous à deux cases en diagonale
des cavaliers vous risquez rien c'est
très long pour voilà c'est le plan
utilisée voilà bel et bien sûr nous qui
réalise son plan les cats est sain et
essayer de casser un peu de cette
structure pour pouvoir un jour mais des
attaques est la cible des six quand elle
quand tu auras un pion arrestation voilà
c'est sur des voleurs ses cibles avec
une idée peut-être sur b4 cscec ensuite
de jouer cavalier en ces quatre là s'est
dispersée selon l'insee le thème faire
pression ça y est on sait un etc
les plans naturel allèles dame qu'on a
vu dans des dizaines de parties de
grands maîtres alors logique dernier
coup des noirs caillou c'est avec l'idée
de jouer protéger 25 la case clé wi et
donc fc mois la cible
il veut absolument imposer la jouerie
ger 6 7 5
sinon il va subir sur les derniers
possible tout de suite mais ils veulent
jouer oui il veut un exemple j'ai de
jouer ça il va imposer s'est imposé
si vous allez tout de suite tout de
suite et ouverture de la colonne a fait
pression
voilà donc ils empêchent le retour david
carr niamey le cavaly mais ils
s'exposent à un échange
oui est là il faudra qu'à une reprise du
pion alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire le
forcing pour vidanger 8 tout simplement
menace angers 6 7 5
ici le cavaly revient il propose nul en
huit ans brille en ligne parce que c'est
parce qu'il a intérêt à ne pas subir le
plan sur la halle dame qui qui serait
bien pour les blancs
il peut aussi échanger les pièces dont
cavaliers prendre d'en prendre en
prendre comprendre et à ce moment là le
pion aux 5 devient un pion en libre est
intéressant pour les noirs quant à eux
qu'on pourrait difficilement attaqué
puisque si on veut l'attaquer par
exemple par f4 anjou apsys pour
consolider ce pion ce pion à eux et
ensuite c'est bien c'est le pion 4 qui
[Musique]
voit là il à breezy d'accord il a pris
ce prix pyongyang comme premier veut
garder les dames
oui parce que sinon les nombreux centres
se changer un oui on va échanger ses
séries et c'était pas mal pour les noirs
qui voudraient soulager leurs jeux ea et
qui aurait eu récupérer gratuitement le
pian et 5 libre c'est vrai mais surtout
mais il ya doublé laon qui est donc un
deuxième pilote payant qui veut garder
les dames les défions doublé par tous
voilà donc il joue du sis pourquoi il
invite les blancs à jouer tu en prends
gestion projet si c'est la tour se
réveille avec une belle colonnes semi
ouverte pour les noirs avaient du jeu
alors peut-être que les blancs vont
boucher par f6 oui on y prend un point
c'est dangereux ça c'est très dangereux
pour le joueur blanc doit travil auront
trop sinueux mais sur la serrure sa
colonne ça y est il à équilibrer le truc
là maintenant il a doublé mais j'aime
bien les doubler j'aime bien la position
noir maintenant il a quand même joli
pion central en scène que j'aimais la
colonne est couvert colonel colonnes de
pression naturelle où il a déjà une pour
poster donc attention c'est quand même
si ce n'est le pied sous le nom final de
pièces lourdes et chance deux nuls sont
quand même important et dans l'est dans
les finales de pièces lourdes finale
deux tours ce qui compte c'est le nombre
de cibles pour les tours et là le fait
d'avoir les pieds en double et b2 et b3
ces deux belles cibles
pour la finale pour la finale deux tours
si une finale deux tours se placer des
pions doublé donc faibles pisier mais on
peut pas bouger
voilà où l'autre on peut d'abord bougies
suis là et après celui-là ils peuvent
pas se protéger les deux indiennes qui
se suivent la voie là peuvent pas s'auto
protéger oui c'est ça mais si c'est des
pions effectivement un peu comme on le
dirait je empoté voilà qui ont doublé
voilà l'arrivée il veut changer les
dames sur il reprendrait du pion bien
évidemment pour contester la colonne est
qu'ils contesteraient le connais que la
colonne ne soit à personne pour faire ma
venue
oui pour un nul et oui donc là la
position c'est quand même un calme et
calmer mais cette colonne f alors je
pense que laurent va garder les dames
maintenant c'est lui qui a intérêt à
garder les dames maintenant pour
travailler sur sur la colonne
[Musique]
à toi la tour f 4 est joué on évite de
les changes de dames et en même temps on
commence à doubler andré parrat le
doublement veut doubler
ils veulent faire la doublette c'est un
coup logique et c'est pour ça que david
a joué le coup tour au dos il protège
tout de suite le ypres otages f2 et
attention la dame la dame pourra
peut-être faire une incursion à cette là
bas où le frêne lara le pion bien sûr le
pion mais c'est toujours la tourte en
irak parce que la 7e et la 8e sont
fragiles chez les ch il est noir est la
septième et la huitième
le fait que les pions du rock est avancé
g6 et agissante avancer là si ça veut
dire que le roi n'a pas trop d'abris sur
les renvois la tour des quatre volets
l'idée tour des quatre il ya évidemment
il bouche cette cette diagonale ben tour
des quatre ans le cas des charges de
dames
il aurait des cibles ensuite avec ses
pions le fion b3 le pion b2 voilà ses
deux pions là oui oui on pourra jouer
autour des 3 pour attaquer le pion pour
attaquer le pion aux trolls de troy donc
effectivement si la tour était venu tout
de suite là sans doute le petit dernier
est peut être une petite en coeur des
problèmes comme on protège mais c'est
qu'on peut pas en fait donc du coup il
ya tous tombent tous qui tombe
et oui c'est difficile ça aurais tu en
voilà échange des dames puis on prend
alors maintenant c'est noir convient
plus alors maintenant les noirs sont des
pions doublé et c'est une finale ont
peut-être qu'il va jouer les fameuses
finales à 4 tours ce qui est le cas ici
qui sont f3 alberto très difficile a
bloqué à manoeuvrer à juger et seront
bloqués en blocs rue complètement les
tubes le lay d'ailleurs ils le jouent
ils le jouent pour fixer on appelle ça
fixe et la faiblesse knicks les pions
doublet sont une faiblesse naturel prof
maintenant ils ne peuvent plus se
libérer sans perte de matériel donc la
faiblesse est fixé finale de pièces
lourdes de huit minutes 57 minutes
devant je prédis un nul
oui je prédis nul dans cette danse est
finalement bien parti pour nulle mais
les
les blancs ont peut être encore un plan
avec tous ces deux puits b 4 à 5
mais qu'est ce qui se passe sur les
quatre il se passa quatre escales voilà
et puis il ya le pion 6-4 et puis on
s'éclate qui voilà donc à cette idée
elle est simple c'est tout et b6 et
d'empêcher ses pions de bouger là ne
peut pas jouer b4 on pourra pas jouer
c'est simple on va fixer les faiblesses
on va fixer des faibles chacun fixe les
faiblesses de l'autre à 5 ensuite il
jouera b6 et une fois que non en voilà
une belle idée fischer a démontré déjà
une idée comme ça paradoxale où la tour
pourras t'appuyer passer devant un de
ses pions pour attaquer le pion de la
colonne la colonne n'est pas ouverte
mais on passe devant le pion dans son
propre pays ont regardé 6e tour attaqué
voilà pour attaquer les la cible donc
belle idée que fisher avait montré une
fois et l'a donc qu'il pourrait troquer
les deux pions b gagné b3 et b2 contre
le pion à 5 contre ce seul pion et d'en
gagner un pion et ensuite et ensuite
faire le siège du pion c4 qui pour
attaquer plusieurs fronts ce pion dans
le pion b3 tombe et celui ci devient
faible donc tout de suite tours 4 tout
de suite 3 4 pour moi c'est ce qu'il a
joué mais gardent quatre évidemment donc
qu'il a il a compris qu'il ya du tout
cet avis puisque là en fait par
transparence il protège ses 4 1 6e puis
on tombe évidence ces cas de méfaits bon
là ils échangent et changer changer
voilà tombé six tours à trois ça va être
nul ça va être muni peut jouer à 4
pourquoi pas oui peut jouer à quatre
coins très intéressés récent à 4 très
intéressante date pour l'en fasciné
qu'est ce qui se passe sur un 4 sur 6 si
ni blanc fonction prend 1,4 dans ce cas
là pour tempérer nos deux échecs échec
et promouvoir sans doute rend à 71,4
avoir s'être préparés laborde tension
parce que les blancs on te croit plus
actifs voilà il faut peut-être préparer
avant de leur wallon arrive peut-être
il faut pas oublier que dans les finales
puisque le roi est une pièce très
importante qui a son rôle à jouer
j'ai 80 très bien joué ça c'est un peu
l'idée que je sais bien jouer jouer gros
1,6 et rojas est sûre il a trouvé une
bonne manière roi créon il ne fait pas
c'est pas grave sa mère dans le purger
quatre parce que le roi va rentrer et
surtout non mais surtout si l'on prête
c'est un pur doublé depuis son île il
est contrôlé par jesse williams seul
puis on arrête de un doublé et est
arrêté par un seul pion les pions doublé
son talent est la case dessin vaut bien
un pion à l'aps le roi sera beaucoup
plus actif ici ce sont les blancs auront
du mal à garder le pion g4 en fait il
faut pas oublier qu'en finale un pur
isolé n'est rien d'autre qu'une case
alors si les civic et la boule et blanc
ont renoncé de jouer h 4 pour contrôler
gsm voilà il ne pas rentrer dans suis
sûr jouer h4 puis roi g3 et prendre un
g4 h4 a l'air tout à fait jouable et
c'est à dire gagner le pion en ayant
conservé la structure des options de
pions parce que si on joue à quatre
contre joue ensuite roger trois roues
apprend et bien plus tard on pourra
jouer g4 le deuxième pion ici sur l'a 4
6 4 et ensuite se crée un pion passer
par un stéroïde de quatre heures on a
même deux pions liés comme ça c'est
mieux que des pions doublé et
inscriptions passé donc oui toujours le
toujours lyon qui a dû aller à dame sens
plus fort qu est donc c'est toujours un
avantage en finale c'est essentiel la
finale les pions passé deviennent très
fort de fait il le fait il l'a eu
plus les mêmes livres comme prévu saint
laurent frayssinet mais si je pense
qu'il a pris la vie de cet homme parce
qu'il va jouer j'ai c'est bien sûr voilà
et bien sûr il va jouer c'est bien sûr
c'est l'idée c'est évident et un jour il
jouera à quatre et il prendra le pion
mais d'un jour pendant longtemps un pass
à va pas tarder après pour pour activer
sa tour samedi jour aussi seront
utilisés parce que satoru sato et active
wheel jour 1 6 3 1 et après je joue
j'essaie voilà donc ici il va jouer g5
je pense j'estime tout de suite non je
pense pas à cause de roger 3 mai sur
g510 là j'ai trois prises mais surpris
d'apprendre je gagnais 2 learn après
l'autre parce qu'il y aura à 4 puis tout
reprend 1 b2 et le plonger de il faudra
s'en occuper il le fait maintenant
maintenant qu'il a dream a jugé sain il
le jouera parce que il le jour après
jour plus tard il le dit faire et c'est
beaucoup plus malin c'est bien que de le
jouer tout de suite c'est malin ça c'est
les les grands maîtres par rapport à
nous à nous on le joue tout de suite
eux ils l'ont vu comme nous ou puis on
prend le droit il a laissé prendre à
elle s'est laissée prendre il a joué
tour à trois essais laisser ben oui il
allait il est revenu il a laissé prendre
il a pris du plomb laurent frayssinet
pourquoi parce que peut-être il y avait
peut-être un blocus général
c'est possiblement est donc là
maintenant le roi blanc va se diriger
vers ces trois pour attaquer deux fois
le pion mais toi mais me salir paon
assis et ça ira ça qu'il n'y a pas
d'accès même si on essaie inclura prisé
n'y aura pas d'accès pour le royaume
d'accès puisque ce pion empêche tout
accès bien sûr leurs réserves
le roi noir n'a pas d'accès donc ça
c'est une configuration l'homme voit
très vite que le roi est dans une espèce
de 2 kg simple c'est plus durs pour
ordinateur ah oui l'ordinateur peut
alors vous pourriez avoir du mal à jouer
ça d'accord
donc tu veux dire que l'ordinateur ou
moins clair comment feront mes seins
donc vous avez vu ce qu'il a fait il a
libéré ses faiblesses tout de suite dans
le milieu de jeu en activant sa tour
semble intéressant au c3 messi roi c3 il
va permettre tour ces cinq échecs et en
c1 et attaques du pion serre et on va
récupérer celui-là celui là où le pion
aux 4 mais non parce que la tour va
protéger
mais elle pour elle pourra pas défendre
une tour qui déforme de choses est une
tour très passive et l'autre sera mobile
très important la mobilité des tours en
finale on qui laisse tomber tous à la
tour tour 1,4 à valider sans doute pour
ces quatre oui oui vous aurez le pion il
le prendre avec le roi ne veut pas
laisser la colonne s'est il veut pas
laisser cette colonne et il pénétra sur
noir et puis là une menace tranquille
qui est tour ces quatre attaques le
fiancé ça voilà tous ces quatre obligé
quasiment tombée c'est alors si on
défend pas si le mario roy c3 puis tours
b 4 et là le roi c'est tranquille à
leroy gagnera la finale
bien sûr j'ai 5 il faut prendre il faut
prendre sur ou si on veut s'amuser on
peut pousser puisque les deux pieds en
valent rien
bon c'est vrai pour qui perd du temps à
venir le chercher avec le roi ouais
c'est vrai c'était pas si idiot que sage
5 il n'ya pas passé il a pas réfléchi
l'abri atteint et la fierté mais c'était
pas si crytek ça ainsi le crétin et oui
parce qu'ils allaient venir oui perdre
du temps avec son roi pour venir changer
le pion et non raciale non croatie 3 il
fait le plan d'un corps l'a dit regardez
comme le pion blanc empêchent l'eau
rendant de passer les deux pions
d'ailleurs le pion l'étoile alors 4-1 en
empêche le roi d'accès droit ne peut pas
passer il faut qu'ils voient là le plan
que la montre et toi c4 ont annoncé
qu'ils mettaient un tour devra exister
coûte avait cité oui oui et maintenant
ils encaissent le pion mais apprendre le
pion d'apprendre le pion mais trois dons
qui les attentions avec quoi le prendre
peut-être avec la tour parce qu'il
faudra défendre g36 dont la tour passera
donc j'ai gagné en géant
illégalité pions ah oui mais il va
revenir d'accord il a pris avec le roi
pour surtout à un jouet tour s'est cabré
tous ses droits pour défendre g3 pour
ces capteurs c3 mais il y a deux simples
mais le problème c'est qu'à de cible il
ya aussi le pion à 4 qui est une cible
n'est pas possible
oui belle finale deux tours la belle
finale deux tours difficiles à juger
égalité deux pions des 6 heures de show
était là qui sourit mieux et vous avez
vu comment jouer les deux grands les
délais de joueurs qui sont de grands
maîtres
l'activité de la tour l'acte i de
l'activité de la touriste finale 5,40
contre 12 50 sarah importance à 2,55
attention ils ont fait signer le temps
nouaille attention laurent frayssinet
attention parce que le pion bevalala il
attaques et contre attaques sur quatre
oui mais même si on prend là bas on
prend 1,4 oui mais là je l'approuvé
échec on récupère du 3 mai il va prendre
g3
c'est une finale tendue caressante
maintenant belle finale voyait les deux
cibles là celui qu'elle plus de cibles
le plus exposé en fait dans une fille
décédée aux lancers des banques et oui
cible c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure dans les six mois si l'on vient
on ferme le roi noir
oui m'emmena ce tour 3 gagner le purger
trois et si la tour défend prend le plus
envie à tour des champions viennent mais
on perd le pion c7 vers le fiancé 7 mai
à prague il ya le pian des cinq par tour
des cas et le fait ça nous prendrait de
suite
il prend tout de suite ça va t'il course
il trop clés du matériel en place
c'est là qu'on apprend par contre ça
libère le roi il va pouvoir passer par
cette case là il faut jouer pour preuve
quatre pour jouer tour des quatre échecs
malin oui attend web 6/0 6/3 f6 tour 17
pour prendre le pion avec tempo à l'onu
femmes avec lâcheté 3,5 alors peut-être
raid 5 et mais là ça peut être nul en
bref si ça oui d'accord s'est il y avait
c'était équivalent les deux oui mais il
va prendre avec échec là aussi oui bien
sûr où ça va être une cour à belle
course depuis hier cinq minutes dominées
cette voie il le fait alors on est
attention parce que le pion b4 libéré là
où oui oui le jeu mais pas s'il aurait
pas dû jouer tout de suite alors le dain
ce genre de position c'est la course
c'est celui qui annoncions le pion blanc
est quand même 16e avancé celui qui
démarre le 1er à la venturi taux déjà
démarré le public danger cas depuis
entendez 5,6 sur un an ils sont à égale
distance et le roi par contre est plus
proche du pion des salazes au les leurs
au nord du pays ont dû plonger bien sûr
le roi noir et proches aussi du pion du
pian passé quelle belle finale quelle
belle finale est difficile à juger
c'est impossible qui va gagner ça le sol
en sang là la moindre perte de temps ça
peut sourire il est le pion et le pion
dame avant l'autre ou lola d'intention
prêtant une attention tchèque roi tout
châtre ou alors là c'est chaud là il a
gagné un temps pour des raisons qui ont
bien sûr à ce mets toujours derrière le
pion attaquent l'euro le pion voilà ils
poussent leurs pions
oui il m'a je vous rejoins voilà les
tours toujours derrière les voyait bien
sûr c'est la manière de dollars us 3
dans les tours contrôler le mieux les
pions à l'échec
échec angers cas peut-être non endroit
deux ou à trois 3 voilà pour défendre
nul ça mais maintenant il va jouer
rouaroua f2 mon rêve d'autres échecs
wave ii roi de windsor au 5 tours 8 il
va peut-être un arrêté il va faire échec
et à chaque fois il va revenir l'un
ouais mais avec le temps il ya peut-être
pouvoir sacrifier la tour et avoir deux
pions contre roy et depuis on compte
retour avec un roi qui vaut une tour
avec un pion qui vaut une tour quand le
pion est trop avancé non parce qu'il
pourra pas non il
je suis de gagner au mans fossiles à
j'ai compris ce qu'il va faire il veut
jouer roi je pensais pas je pensais que
voulait ce qu'est ce qui vous pensez que
vous l'aimez pas la catin sol est nul
parce qu'à chaque fois que le roi
revient il revient et voilà ça y est il
va essayer de gagner dix minutes 8
non non non quatre mois trois mille deux
minutes deux croyait faisait forcément
f3 pour être à 100 mais tu ne savais
tenue le 18 puis yahia il ya équipes de
l'avionneur va essayer de l'équilibré
vrai équilibre équilibre de la terreur
des aéroports très belle pole position
une place s'est terminée vers d'un nul
comme vous pouvez le voir la tour
blanche très bien placé derrière le
client l'empêchent d'avancer était que
le roi s'approche du plan pour soutenir
pour les dalles et la promotion il ya un
échec très difficile de progresser dans
ces conditions ils ont donc vers une
petite pause
[Musique]
oh
ans
[Musique]